president Trump ripping into Democrats
and calling out the Supreme Court after
a pair of his decisions on taxes the
High Court ruling the president does not
have absolute immunity from prosecution
and that a New York District Attorney
can subpoena his tax returns and in a
separate case the Supreme Court blocking
House Democrats from getting their hands
on Trump's financial records for now
both of those cases are being thrown
back to lower courts here's the
president's reaction this is a political
witch hunt Alexa which nobody's ever
seen before it's a pure witch hunt it's
a hoax
just like the molar investigations a
hoax that I won and this is another hoax
this is purely political I win at the
federal level and we won very decisively
and so they send it into New York and
you know what's going on in New York
everyone's leaving it's turned out to be
a hellhole and they better do something
about it because people are leaving New
York is a political witch-hunt it just
continues and Nancy Pelosi responding to
the rulings by vowing to keep
investigating the president we have a
path that the Supreme Court has laid out
that we certainly will not ignore and we
will never stop our oversight this isn't
so much about the president's records
although we'd like to know you know how
Russia funded his operation all of you
but that's not what was it stick what
was at stake is the president about the
wall all right Kennedy here's what I
don't like about this they're gonna get
their hands on these tax returns and
then they're just gonna leak them and
then you're back to the whole Russia
thing where these mysterious people are
leaking things you don't know if it's
know if it's true or not and then it
just spins up a lot of fake news and
speculation it's pretty unfair well it's
interesting because I I'm one of the
people I think more information is
better I would like to see everyone's
tax returns who wants to be the most
powerful person in the world I don't
have a problem with that I do have a
problem with the overt politicization
and that's what the supreme court
blocked today and and they made note
that this is what the framers wanted to
make sure didn't overtake the branches
of government and they didn't want the
the Congress to be able to Hector the
president with superfluous requests and
so they they did block that down but
also we you have to see her is you know
this was not a slim majority this was a
seven to two ruling in two cases that
were lumped together here and gore
search and Cavanaugh were two justices
that although they agreed with the
majority opinion they also made note
that the president should have some
claims to block certain requests in the
lower courts and you know to your point
about leaking the process through the
lower courts now may take so much time
that if the president is worried about
these things being known before the
November election because it's going
back and has a restart that may be
politically favorable to him one why do
you guys have to keep hectoring the
president with superfluous requests well
you know at first I just want to say I
thought Kennedy was on target overall I
mean the the key thing here for the
president in the short term is that his
taxes will not likely be out in public
before the November election so in the
short term I think you know although we
saw him with his hands across his chest
looking very defensive and talking about
Obama and witch hunts I think if you're
looking at it politically Jesse he
really came out on top in terms of the
Congress not having immediate access to
the records but in the long term I think
the big ticket here is that you have a
conservative Supreme Court saying very
clearly that in terms of prosecution in
terms of investigation that the
president is not above the law that
everybody every American including the
president has to respond to legal
subpoenas and actions in that regard and
I think that's a that's something that
goes beyond the political moment goes
beyond every president said he was could
not be investigated couldn't be
prosecuted could shoot a man on Fifth
Avenue he even said he could pardoned
himself well here's a Supreme Court
saying that's not the case mr. president
the nope no Kings around here I don't
know if that's exact
we what the ruling stated but that's
neither here nor there Dana how do you
see this SCOTUS ruling it's hard for me
to see anything because you're not
wearing a tie and I don't understand why
it's a long story thrown off that I am
flabbergasted ok so this decision might
have been a huge bang to the end of the
Supreme Court session instead it's just
a little bit of a whimper and that's
because of all the things that have
already been said the White House press
secretary today in her briefing she
described the decisions as a win for the
president and I thought that that was I
thought it was skillful the way that she
handled those questions and also she's a
lawyer so it really helps and I think
that that was the best way to do it and
I would not talk about this much more
because this is not going to happen and
nothing's gonna happen before the
election what this did ensures that
there's going to be a lot more
litigation going forward what Andy
McCarthy and Jon you two intellectual
legal scholars that we all listen to one
of the things they said is it might be a
political win for the president today
but it was a drastic terrible decision
for the presidency the office of the
presidency because going forward this
basically means that any US attorney
that wants to basically drag any sitting
president into court is going to be
allowed to do so
so there's some caution there but I
think overall for the president not a
bad day yeah I mean Greg you've told me
in the green room many times that's one
of the reasons you're not running for
the presidency because you just don't
want to have your taxes exposed to the
American people you have a very complex
tax return and you just don't want
Americans to see that yeah there are a
lot of unusual medical deductions that I
think and it would just keep it would
just confuse the public by the way Dana
I will tell you why Jesse's not wearing
a tie great news they are rebooting
falcon crest and jesse is playing
Lorenzo Lamas is role I think his name
was lance cumson approximately please do
please do we don't see manly chest I'm
so distracted so let me back up yes
there you go here's the deal I want to
make two points
the fact is Trump won the presidency he
was given and we know this anybody was
given a choice beforehand release your
taxes and potentially potentially muck
up the campaign don't release them and
if you lose nobody cares and if you win
great you won and we can deal with that
problem later about not releasing the
taxes so this was very smart strategy if
from 2016 or to saying hey let's just
see what happens now it also pays to
point out what energizes the media
they're always consumed by in any
potential avenue of muck regarding
people who don't share their assumptions
so everybody becomes a Woodward and
Bernstein about around the people they
hate but imagine if the media had been
this energized about Harvey Weinstein
ten years ago or Jeffrey Epstein ten
years ago or the decay of democratic
cities twenty thirty years ago or just
recently the scandalous rest home deaths
or baby hunter Biden's enriching himself
off his dad or who pushed the steel
dossier I mean we haven't heard about
the steel dossier the Clinton funded
author of it Christopher steel has been
ordered to pay damages on the dossier
lies so the bottom line here is media
bias isn't always about the stories that
the media chases it's the stories they
pretend that don't exist that's a good
point so why doesn't the president maybe
just acid wash his returns because
that's what Hillary did and no one
really seemed to care there